morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy Thursday hope
everyone is having a fabulous morning so
far
Jackie and I here to deliver everything
you need to know lots going on in the
world today we have all you need to know
about Naya Rivera there's so much going
on really very devastating story which
we will get into very sad news to wake
up to we will talk about it a lot is
going on today I feel like I'm finally
getting my looks back together
yes she's wearing a Luke now to look a
little so it's like my hair my makeup
just everything has been out of sorts
otherwise something Crazy's been
happening this week like I've been
looking better than you and that never
happened so because I've been putting in
so much effort like you know after this
week is over like I'm done putting an
effort know I've been putting an effort
to but I just I couldn't get into my
bathroom my hairspray my curling iron so
like I've just been a mess I think today
I tried to figure it out as best I could
a fabulous oh thank you so much I am
wearing lady gang Express this is the
cutest from forever I'm so excited that
they send it to me I'm never gonna take
it off it's so cute I got a box - I did
not get that romper and I saw Becca
Tilly we aren't wearing it and I'm like
oh my god she got this romper and then
you got it - I guess like one half of
every podcasting duo has to have it
right Tonya probably didn't get it right
I'm worried because you're born in July
I'm such a Tonya oh it's being important
to July my birthday is weirdly tomorrow
weirdly and I haven't spoken about it
because it's so depressing like I don't
even want to acknowledge it one because
it's one thing to like get older and
have to change your birthday but at
least you get like a party in exchange
like there's there's a deal there's a
barter happening on birthdays like all
right I'll get older but let me black
out with my friends I don't get that I'm
just getting older and it does gifts
you'll get gift
yeah but you know material items have
really never been of importance to me a
much more about experiences and I say
that as a joke but I really do mean that
like a much more experiential than I am
materialistic and I don't get that this
year like for the record material items
mean everything to me you know that's
why we're we're sober but I will I will
say that in this pandemic like they mean
at less and less to the point they mean
almost nothing Jenny like it's just it's
over the party's over
no pandemics change people yeah they do
I've definitely been changed in that way
speaking of pandemics changing people
the pandemic has really taken a hit on
the morning toast because we announced
yesterday but in case you didn't say we
are we made the decision to cancel camp
toast it had originally been postponed
from May to September I think we thought
September we would be totally in the
clear but now that September is upon us
we are not in the clear
and we just didn't feel right about
having people travel from different
parts of the country and with no way to
really ensure that we could do
everything properly incorrectly so we
decided to cancel camp the campers
already know they've got their emails
but if you're a camper and you didn't
know right you will be getting every
firing from Eventbrite we are so sorry
but it is what it is I think that was
the best decision like I feel I feel
good about it even though I'm obviously
sad that there will be no camp this year
I feel like it's the right thing to do
104 all the campers and the counselors
counselors are important too of course
they are so if you are camper we're
gonna miss you and if you are camper you
didn't see the email here you go here's
your email or you're not in the Facebook
group right here's your post yeah so
that was sad but again right decision
yeah I agree
so things are just happening things are
happening with Fast Five and we have
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills which
was finally dating it was back it did
take me like two hours together I'm not
gonna lie me but I was just distracted
or it was a bad episode I can't tell
anymore I have a theory which I will
talk about at the TV recap because last
night's episode was definitely strange
oh okay good I'm glad that I'm not the
only one who felt that way okay before
we get into the past five stories
there's something that cloud and I want
to talk about because earlier this week
football player on the Eagles just Sean
Jackson posted some very anti-semitic
remarks on his Instagram we had decided
like yesterday that we weren't or we
didn't even talk about it but we I just
felt like we weren't gonna talk about it
because people like to complain that we
only talk about issues when they pertain
to us and so that's a criticism that I
recognize so we weren't going to talk
about it but then yesterday it dawned on
me that if we don't talk about it like
really no one else is talking about it
honestly I was okay yesterday not
addressing it cuz I'm like you know let
the media handle it like they handle it
with with all these types of situations
like I felt comfortable just like
letting it slide because we don't really
talk about stuff like this on our show
even though we are you know in the last
couple weeks trying to leverage the
platform for more you know social
justice issues but just seeing that like
literally nobody's talking about this
like it gave me a Pitt and Jewish guilt
is real and we have so many Jewish
followers and we are so proudly Jewish
that it seemed a little strange of us
not to address it and he like were some
of really the most influential young
Jewish voices um and I was looking at
other people on my Instagram because
recently my Instagram timeline is just a
flood of activism you know and there's
nothing I think I can I have a few
people who I follow where Jewish who
posted it very few not one non-jewish
person that I follow and it's really
concerning that no one is talking about
it deshaun has apologized and um I I
felt his video to be very sincere by the
way so do not and I honestly at this
point I'm ready to forgive him and move
on I feel like a lot of people are
speaking out to let him know at Julian
Edelman posted a video why what he said
was so wrong and and I do believe that
he gets it and I'm ready to forgive him
but what concerns me is the fact that no
one really seems to care that
anti-semitism just soars up gets this
past when it's like one of the longest
oldest forms of history in the book and
like if you saw what do Shawn had posted
well so can we break it up and there's
to me I totally agree there's two things
going on there's the incident and then
there's the outcry right and to me it's
like I have maybe this is just me being
so naive but I take a very gracious
standpoint on canceled culture do I
think DeSean Jackson should be fired
cancelled no I really I genuinely don't
and maybe I'm just being so naive but
like I can really see this as someone
who is completely uneducated in the
subject and I know it sounds so crazy
like you're posting a Hitler quote like
it sounds so crazy but you know what
it's like to us it's insane we grew up
very Jewish we grew up where the
Holocaust you learn it in every subject
it's a subject of every [ __ ] dinner
all your grandparents all your ancestors
it is so engrained in you Holocaust I've
been to Poland M into a concentration
camp I've been to Yad Vashem like I've
been everywhere like to me it's insane
that someone wouldn't know not to post a
Hitler quote but at the end of the day
like people's experiences are so much
different than mine and part of me
really wants to believe this was like a
huge oversight and a lack of judgment
and a huge amount of ignorance and I
don't know maybe people are not gonna
agree with me on that but that's really
how I feel and I'm always ready for an
opportunity to give someone a little bit
of
and room to grow because in my opinion
if DeSean Jackson really felt this way
he idolized Adolf Hitler and Louis
Farrakhan like two very very well-known
proud anti-semites crowd and he posted
that that's not something you backtrack
on like you post it and you can double
down right so because it's a crazy thing
to post if you're gonna post it like you
own at least I own it but he didn't so
which really made me believe he did not
understand it and furthermore he
apologized multiple times on camera
which i think is so much harder to do
and it's you know not that he could get
away with it in other cities but this is
Philly like a really big Jewish
community Pennsylvania Pittsburgh the
Squirrel Hill shooting literally two
years ago like it is a huge Jewish
community and while I was disappointed
incredibly and offended by what he
posted I do think there is value in how
you respond and I was grateful that he
apologized now of course an apology
doesn't just get you forgiveness I do
hope that he really leans in I heard
that he's meeting a lot with different
rabbis in like Hillel Philadelphia and I
really hope that's true like I do and
Julian Edelman offered to take him to
Yad Vashem and exact thing that we need
right now but - exactly the ansel
culture don't need cancel culture and we
are not advocating for cancel culture
one bit but the people like on my
timeline who are just constantly posting
about hate and calling it out where they
see it and calling it out of random
Karen's in the supermarket you have
absolutely no platform but won't call it
out when it's a person with a million
followers and it makes you feel as a Jew
that anti decision that anti-semitism is
just not that important and that's a
really scary feeling yeah and the kind
of I've really been trying to read as
much as I can and just like get people's
vibe because what I'm seeing is that
like a lot of people are reluctant to
speak up about it because they don't
want to take any spotlight away from the
black lives matter movement which has
really made remarkable progress in the
last five or six weeks and I and I hear
that but at the same time you can't
really ever drive out racism if
anti-semitism lights all the stage the
same hatred so to feel like you'd be
taking kind of spotlight away from one
they're really the same and honestly
with all this kind of educating we've
been doing and just watching Selma one
of the biggest takeaways I took away
from Selma and just from all these types
of different movies and podcasts in
general is that like the black community
can't drive out racial inequality by
themselves like it has to be
group thing you saw in summer like when
they tried to March by themselves they
were stopped when people from all around
the world came different religious
leaders you saw a priest and a rabbi
like there's power in inclusivity so to
to feel like you can't talk about
anti-semitism without it being like a
slight two races it's not a competition
now it's all hate it's all comes from
the same place so honestly it would
behoove us to just talk about it all
mention it all right you know yeah and I
I was thinking a lot about you sent me a
fabulous video from Bill Maher um a
couple maybe like two weeks ago maybe
yeah yeah and I feel like it really
encapsulated how I feel about canceled
culture and it was essentially just
saying like I think we should operate in
the mindset where like the person who
made a joke or said something bad or may
posted something by mistake is operating
more from a place of ignorance than
bigotry and if we treat them like bigots
they're just gonna revert into their
corner and be like oh the Jews hate me
they were in my life and maybe you made
Jews even more even if he did just start
like it's so counterproductive and I
totally agree with that and I would like
to apply that Bill Maher formula here
right now because I I am a Jew like I'm
a very proud you and I'm the type of
person who would be offended by a Hitler
quote I would I really would call me
crazy I would well it well so it wasn't
even a Hitler quote it was misquoting
yeah but it so doesn't even matter um
I'm the type of person who would be
offended I can get my pitchfork out and
I could really you know march on to
Philadelphia and say I want him fired
but honestly I would much rather use
this as a teachable moment and what's so
ironic to me about this whole thing is
why his quotes were so dangerous is
these are these are not new stereotypes
about you know we control the media
we're trying to take over the world to
extort America which is so absurd and
was was the basis for the Holocaust I
think that's important to note yeah but
if let's play into this trope when we
own the media we own all the banks okay
I don't know what a bank I would like to
but I don't if we own the media don't
you think more people would be talking
about this it's just so ironic it's like
we own the media but no one's covering
the anti-semitism it's just so stupid
and it's but people really believe it
and it's like it's talking people and
it's frustrating like we joke and we've
joked about this sort of thing before
like the protocols of the Elders of Zion
and how that seems like so backwards
where Jews are like plotting to take
over the world but no it's it's on
Instagram in 20
right this week it's very real and it's
so dangerous and I just don't think it's
something worth brushing off I agree
I completely agree so we felt the need
to say something um and if you hadn't
heard about it now you have and you know
what if it weren't for Ben he was like
go to Josh on Jackson's Instagram I'm
like who is that and honestly if it
weren't for Ben I probably would not
have heard about it which is so scary
because I'm so involved in like the
Jewish community and I'm so involved in
pop culture literally I'm on Twitter
24/7 I could like I'm it's really
disappointing that I didn't hear about
it especially I think I spent double the
time than usual looking for stories and
I did not see it right it's just it's
disappointing because all these football
players have such big platforms there's
such leaders in their communities so
many people young and old look up to
them and to not make like a more of a
teachable moment out of this or just
really say anything at all is really
disappointing to me as a Jew and as a
human being
I agree but that's that on that mm-hmm
and now it's time yes for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast fabulous fabulous yes
let's get into it the first story of the
day was the very sad news that we woke
up to that Naya Rivera is missing after
her four-year-old son was found alone in
a boat on a California Lake Naya Rivera
is missing after a trip to a California
Lake Fillmore Police Department confirms
two people on Wednesday the Glee star
was reported missing after a trip to
Lake Peru in Ventura County California
the actress and her four year old son
Josie Dorsey rented a pontoon boat and
were swimming in the water after the
boat was overdue for return after the
three-hour rental staff of the lake
founded at the north side of the body of
water with her sleeping son aboard but
not Rivera a search and rescue operation
was undertaken at the lake but she was
not found according to the Fillmore
Police Department Authority suspended
the search for the night the plan to
resume on Thursday today thank God she
rented the boat like if it was her boat
no one would have went out looking for
them yeah and the kid who knows what
would have happened at night on a boat
alone it's so scary and it's so sad and
this might be one of the worst stories
I've heard in a really long time at
least in time it's so terrible it's so
unclear what happened
I have to assume that this is like some
if she drowned this is like this has to
have been accidental and I was reading a
little bit people say that this
particular Lake is susceptible to
drownings because sometimes it can
create some sort of a whirl a whirlpool
which might be what happened here um I
don't know it's just I can't I can't
imagine being that kid you know like
seeing your mom disappear and then being
left alone on a boat in the middle of
nowhere completely by yourself and just
like falling asleep yeah thank God that
they found him they and God let's hold
out hope and prayer is that yeah she's
okay she's found it's just such a like a
creepy story and so devastating and it's
just a part of I mean there's this whole
Glee cast is just like not people say
it's cursed but it's it's not
necessarily thriving no I mean this is
just the saddest story so we'll keep you
posted as news comes out but I hope I'm
right behind her okay next story some
drama for Lady Anne ths oh my god this
is real [ __ ] drama the band formerly
known as Lady Antebellum files lawsuit
against Lady a-after singer asked for 10
million dollars so the country band
formerly known as Lady Antebellum which
changed its name to Lady a in June has
filed a lawsuit against seattle-based
blues artist Anita white who has been
performing under the moniker Lady a in a
filing submitted to what on Wednesday to
Nationals US District Court for the
Middle District of Tennessee and
obtained by people attorneys for the
band alleged that White's new legal
counsel delivered a draft settlement
agreed that include an exorbitant
monetary demand after the two parties
had a discussion about continued
coexistence under the name lady egg okay
though a dollar figure was not listed in
the suit the band said in a statement
that white had asked for ten million
dollars a rep for white and the firm
listed as her legal counsel in the suit
did not immediately respond to people's
requests for comment quote today we are
sad to share that our sincere hope to
join together with Anita white and unity
and common purpose has ended she and her
team have demanded a ten million dollar
payment so reluctantly we have come to
the conclusion that we need to ask a
court to affirm our right to continue to
use the name lady a a trademark we have
held for many years the group said in a
statement
this is so bad because because you want
to know why regardless of in the eyes of
the law like who's right in the court of
public opinion this is what it looks
like it looks like Lady Antebellum
changed their name in solidarity with
the black lives matter movement and in
an effort to eradicate hate and now
they're suing a black artist like that
just from literally no purview does that
look good no it doesn't look good at all
um I'm trying to understand why like so
they want to just both be lady a which I
feel like could work well she she only
agreed to it if they pay her ten million
dollars and it's my understanding that
she was using the moniker before that
for sure but they have the trademark yes
but whoever uses it first that in
trademarks it's like you can get the
trademark but if there's proof of
someone using it before you it overturns
it yeah a right of refusal or say I have
the trademark yep I know I don't even
know if they need to be asking I think
that they do well maybe in the court of
public opinion but in the court right I
don't know I don't know I I'm unsure
about the legality of this all but all I
know is that like as a you know a
consumer just like watching this whole
thing it doesn't look good like for them
at all it look it looks very bad it
looks very bad but I hope that they can
figure this out the lab and then collab
yeah no but like you know what it's like
obviously whoever it's like running this
operation on behalf of Lady Antebellum
was trying to be proactive in changing
the name and they've kind of like undone
the good deed that they did because now
it's just like it's so it's so
contentious it's so messy it's so bad
like I don't really understand the
thinking here no but what else could
they be called if not lady a lady Antony
chess yeah or Lady Anne Tian oh yeah or
lady and TV key that's it you named it
will write them a letter and let them
know we've come up with their new name
yeah you can call me lady aunt or what
about lady aunty yeah and then they're
just like your name your auntie's it
just it was an easy name change for them
because Fitness parking their fans
really call them lady a yeah so this
legal obstacle is obviously not ideal
for them but I do think they can and she
be handling it a little better and just
understanding you know what it may look
like to an outsider like a big country
band of course doing a small you know
black artist it just it don't look good
I recommend lady ante because everybody
loves an auntie how about lady cousin
you know what why would some justice for
lady uncle Lady uncle lady you okay some
more music news we got a little music
news oh wait is that the music news
brought to you by grab hub yes fabulous
I'm already hungry just talking about
this brand um grab it was fabulous
because you can explore restaurants that
deliver near to you I literally use grab
for dinner last night
it's so easy to find food that you crave
and order through the GrubHub app search
by cuisine restaurant name or menu item
and the app will help filter your
results accordingly GrubHub helps you
enjoy your favorite restaurants with new
perks and exclusive rewards you can get
a $10 perk every time you order
available all day every day at select
restaurants stay safe and support the
restaurants you love slash local
restaurants with curbside pickup and
contact free delivery on GrubHub
honestly and you know in normal days
there's no reason not to use grab hub
but today more than ever there's
literally not a reason in the world not
to use grub hub because not only can you
support local businesses financially but
you also don't have to leave your house
and you can stay safe and flatten the
curve you can get a ten dollar perk you
so if you get a ten dollar perk now you
can enjoy dinner after this episode or
lunch pretend it depending what time
you're gonna eat it's a fabulous brand
and a fabulous service that now has all
these fabulous perks so if you download
the grub hub app you can get $10 off
your first order or for $10 off your
first order of $30 or more every day
participant participating restaurants
that's $10 off your order of $30 or more
every day from participating restaurants
so download the grub hub app today and
get $10 off your order of $30 or more
it's literally just so fabulous I don't
feel like though the brand really speaks
for itself no it does and I think that
we should place an order via grub hub
right after the show probably maybe you
should order it now
Pizza um uh yeah maybe what do you mean
oh I don't know I just like it's a
little early but I could do Chinese -
Emily Palace love it okay some music
news Harry Styles will lovingly tell you
stories till you fall asleep via the
app falling asleep to the sound of Harry
Styles soft British accent may sound
like a dream to some but it's becoming a
reality for all the popular sleep and
meditation app comm announced it will be
partnering with the singer in a new
sleep story series called
dream with Harry which launches on
Wednesday the former One Direction er
sent fans into a frenzy with the release
of his fine line album and cheeky
watermelons sugar a music video
swimmingly dedicated to touching his
ravenous fans stop at nothing just to
get a little closer to the star and now
they can get even closer this is such a
great idea for like whoever is ahead of
Business at calm and like once and I'll
make this in industry where they where
they pay celebrities it's absolutely
genius because you know as a as a 13
year old there's very there's a lot of
money I would pay to like have Joe Jonas
sing me to sleep like this is just
really a brilliant idea and a great way
to acquire customers ya know it's very
smart he does have a very soothing voice
and I think that they're gonna they're
gonna see a lot of new customers on the
on the topic of like calm and all that
stuff I have been listening to ASMR okay
I discovered this girl Josie on tick
tock I think I've spoken about her
before and she does he's kind of like
makeup spa videos where it's like she'll
pretend you're like she's rubbing your
scalp and like I swear to god you can
feel that on your scalp and I'm so
desperate for a massage like this is
where quarantine has got me too we run
like feigning imagining a massage on my
scalp in from of YouTube video but so
I've taken her take talking videos and
now I watch her on YouTube and she does
like 45 minutes of all sessions that put
me to sleep and Ben came in the other
night and I was like a half asleep but
listening to this girl Josie gave me a
scalp massage
it was so confused it's like what are
you doing and I'm like I was so annoyed
because like i was really in like a
trance transitory state like i'm about
to fall asleep but i can't recommend it
enough I know ASMR is very triggering
for people but she's very calming she's
all these like beautiful music sounds
and she talks like she's a specialist
she's like flipped over on your back now
and I'm like ready to flip over oh my
god I hate flipping over let me chew
it's the worst part of a massage I can't
wait to get a massage yeah no that's
gonna be a while you'll be waiting for a
while but I'm excited that you've found
I looked it up
massages and like those types of spas
are opening in phase 7,000
it'll be a while sounds about right yeah
sounds about right
well head over to come if you want the
smooth sounds at Harry Styles voice I'm
on the side of like Mike tick-tock so
I've now fallen into Harry Styles stand
and they're freaking out like they can't
believe that oh that's exciting yeah I
mean one Margo wash ray is thrilled
about this yeah you know I like love
Harry Styles do I want him to talk to me
on my way to sleep I don't think so
well then you're just not a real Stan no
I'm not I think that's the difference
but do you have a fan and a Stan so true
are you a true to this person as you
fall asleep I'm not okay
next story is an ongoing story that's um
in day three today might be day four of
Amber Heard Johnny death are in court
and the stuff that is coming out is so
crazy yeah I we won't even begin to
scratch the surface on this show but
it's like the biggest thing happening
right now
they are literally like the messiest
people on planet earth like this is and
I'm not even sure what lawsuit this is
because they got divorced now I think
Johnny Depp is suing Amber Heard for
defamation yes because a newspaper
called him I think that he that's
claiming that he beat her okay um so in
just one of many stories like literally
there's no one to sum it up because the
the things that are that are coming out
of these depositions are just [ __ ]
wild and if you read one person's case
you're like wow the other person's a
monster you read one person's case
you're like wow the other person is a
monster I have no idea but most recently
Johnny Depp has been accused of
attacking Amber Heard for withholding
meds during a detox also the detail of
the story's like yesterday I saw a story
that Amber Heard shot in the bed praying
she's definitely and then it was like I
guess she was maybe gonna blame it on
the dogs but Johnny was like it was too
big to be a dog [ __ ] like it was just
the level of detail of the [ __ ] was just
not something I ever thought I would
read like they they are so they
obviously had such a [ __ ] problematic
relationship and I can't be healthy for
either of them to keep drudging through
it so publicly but we just don't need to
know about but he was also saying like
when she first met him that he was
trying to say like she's like so
calculating like sociopath whatever that
when she first met him she said that
like she loved his movie so much
button and like later into their
relationship like she said that she's
never seen one I've honestly I have
never seen the Johnny John move II I
except for Willy Wonka Oh fabulous
classic
but I've never seen Pirates of the
Caribbean or whatever else he's in
Narnia um but Johnny Depp allegedly
attacked Amber Heard when she withheld
his meds while he was supposed to be
detoxing on his private Caribbean island
his libel trial heard Thursday private
of the Caribbean the Pirates of the
Caribbean star went to his Caribbean
island little halls Pond Cay in the
Bahamas in August 2014 sounds too low
that sounds delightful
with his then fiancee at Amber Heard
acting like a nurse he told London's
High Court he is alleged to have slapped
the actress and cater to the ground
while having spasms and shakes from
coming off of roxies or Roxy codone a
brand name for the addictive opioid
oxycodone all the sudden he's flipping
again heard texted one of his doctors
according to the report just started
screaming he was so mad so he pushed me
and I asked him to get out she allegedly
wrote so this is just another instance
of what she said she has signs
um there's a video like that went viral
during a lot of these allegations being
made where he's like in the kitchen
[ __ ] slamming a bunch of cabinets and
glasses and in the video you don't see
him necessarily abusing her but it's
indicative of a very very bad type of
behavior and I do stand with Amber Heard
ya know this is clearly a very toxic
relationship it's unfortunate that they
have to relive it and we're all there
with them um and it's so messy and like
I get that like that's how the court
works so like everything is public
domain but like I'm really like not
interested in hearing about someone
taking a [ __ ] in someone else's bed you
know right that's where I personally
draw the line that's where I draw the
line as well call me conservative but
that's a really crazy thing like for her
to do as a prank no that's insane
Ben would leave me yeah if like that's
that's great even if I took like Theo's
[ __ ] and like put it on Ben's pillow he
would leave me obviously it was
disgusting disgusting and like someone
else had to clean that up of course I'd
be like a poor housekeeper Hey just
ain't right that ate
can write okay fit the battle story some
potential good airline news because CNN
business is reporting how the pandemic
may change Airlines much-hated $200 e
booking fees something that needs to be
changed a while ago but I do think that
this pandemic will will kind of change
some of the issues that a lot of us have
had had with the airline right system
the airline industry is so problematic
of course to mg dollar change fees are
us just a blimp on the radar of things
that are wrong with airline industry I
think what is most concerning and I
think a huge part of why this pandemic
spread so fast is the inhumane way they
treat humans like cattle on airplanes
yeah unless you paid three thousand
dollars for a seat in first class
right which is elitism at its finest
mm-hmm airlines have done away with
their $200 change fees giving passengers
the flexibility they've long desired at
a time when few people are traveling
none of the major US airlines have
signaled they will abandon chase thieves
altogether but as the pandemic continues
to spread they have repeatedly delayed
their deadlines for re-implementing fees
Delta and American Airlines for example
recently extended their no change fee
policy through September and United
pushed its deadline to July 31st well
the clock is ticking on that one you
might want to push it again because it
doesn't look like things are gonna be
changing anytime soon and if any bigwigs
at any airlines are watching this show
which I'm sure that you are I really
implore you to do the right thing here
and understand that a lot of your
customers have lost their jobs we're in
a national crisis people are gone and
but when things go back to normal and
everyone's ready to travel again we will
remember the airlines that stood up for
us and did the right thing and the
airlines that you know waited till July
31st you know what I mean yeah I know
you think that like everyone's too busy
to take note of what you're doing we're
not I'm not busy at all
speaking of airlines from what I've
heard from other people's accounts
traveling right now is actually feeling
very um safe and clean and
well-organized so it depends
I spoke to TPG according to TPG there
have been major major precautions being
taken on airlines a lot of them being
that they're giving away masks and hand
sanitizer and you have to wear the masks
the whole time and they're not selling
middle seats but some airlines are
skirting around some of the protocols
I've heard that American Airlines is
selling full flights which is just not
not it like children or shoulder-width
random strangers it's just not what we
need right now so I've heard both yeah
but I think we got like we'll give them
some credit where it's due but I do also
think that a revamp of the system is
overdue it never made sense those
changes anyway like why can't you book a
ticket and be flexible and that work on
me yes the airline industry has like
continued throughout history been like
one of the most rigid and difficult to
work with like why booking a ticket it's
like literally going to jail like you
cannot do anything and it's like such a
big deal to even think of moving like
it's so dramatic like people's plans
change chill the [ __ ] out plans change
god man plans and God laughs so we're
gonna have to switch my flight make a
plan
I'm making a plan I'm God laughing okay
okay there was anything you needed to
know that you definitely did and I'm so
excited because we were gonna dive into
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills which
was back after a two-week hiatus and it
is my understanding after watching last
night's episode that they took those two
weeks to rieta Tepes ODEs to give
themselves a little bit more time
because after they all left Kyle's house
nothing happened in this episode they
literally went doctor's office em sculpt
back to Kim's doctor's office like Kim
is not even a main character why we had
to go to one but not one but two of her
doctor's office I did i watch Kim's
breasts be like like her going under
this the night yeah when she's not a
main cast member but literally the
beginning of the episode was the
barbecue by Kyle's in the end of the
episode was settings and everything in
between I think was just put - I feel
like they're just trying to delay the
good stuff so as to when they can get
back to filming confessionals and
hopefully have an in-person reunion
that's what I think because last night's
episode was very choppy like so much
[ __ ] like Garcelle moving Erica and
Lisa at the dr. Kim at the dr. Kim and
Kyle driving kmac I'll back at the
Jarman Kyle died it was such a strange
edited choppy random episode with such
like mediocre content sandwiched between
two decent scenes that I have to believe
it was edited in this two-week hiatus so
that they can drag out the season so
that they can do the proper
confessionals alongside I think because
for there were some zoom computers some
and they were much better than New York
like Kyle obviously like got it together
like they were it was just it was better
than New York but it still wasn't great
but the s part it was previously
recorded confessionals and then a few
zoom confessionals yeah which which I
can work with yeah um next week looks
like it's the big episode but I can just
see next week they end the episode right
as Denis is about to walk up to brandy
like so I feel like maybe the week after
is the one that's coming but I guess
let's talk about the same thing we've
been talking about Denis the kids bad
mothers where do we stand I like I don't
really stand on either side I just like
love how to eat it's like really
actually a good friend too she is that's
how you be a good friend you check in
and you shouldnt engage when they were
all in the tent like making fun of Denis
she was playing cornhole with the kids
see I feel for Denis but Denis it's a
little bit hypocritical because she's
been so open about like sexual stuff on
the show so how are these women to know
that this specific dinner they shouldn't
do this and they didn't know that the
kids could hear like it really was going
out of proportion and I think that Denis
needs to let it go a little bit I guess
that's what she's saying is she's trying
to she doesn't want to talk about it
anymore but the women like want to beat
this dead horse until what maybe they
get an apology from Denis for making
them feel bad but like no I XI Denis
said her piece and then wanted it to be
over but it's like her piece made those
women look like but it wasn't mom
shaming that's the wrong word but it
made them look like they were
irresponsible in front of kids so Denis
can say her piece but the others can't
but she doesn't want to hear it they all
should say their piece in Santa Barbara
and they just keep saying their piece
and until we get it we're gonna agree to
disagree on this we like honestly I'm
not a mother I don't know what it's like
to sit at the table and the kids are
there and be free spirited outside of
him the rest of my life and where I draw
that line so I really can't say but I do
she said at the table multiple time the
kids are here the kids are here and like
it really was sort of a kids party and I
think I think there was a little I do
see where Denis is initial concerning
from the place that it's gotten to now
is absurd Aaron versus the women is
absurd and I love to read coming in with
her two cents like listen sweetie my
first season my husband's stood up for
me too and it's the biggest mistake you
can make keep Aaron at home and she's
right it never ends well when it's just
one husband if it's like all the
husband's when Ken called Yolanda a
stupid woman like and then all the
husbands got involved that is
okay and when it's like husband verse
like even in Potomac when Karen was
going to say it Ashley's beach house and
Michael showed it out and so ray spoke
to Michael like there's a dynamic where
the couples can argue together but when
it's Aaron verse the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills it's just never gonna end
well for you know when he was being so
condescending and so rude and that's
where he lost me and I love to Erica
just really standing up for herself like
stop treating us like we're [ __ ] kids
we're the same age as you we're just
women and you think you could talk down
to us I really didn't like the way Aaron
was being but can you live with yourself
yeah it was like Kim you are doing just
fine they're doing just fine it was just
so condescending and so rude and I
really and Denise is so like I can't
tell if she was being playing dumb or
was just being dumb leaving to go to the
bathroom leaving Aaron with all these
women like what are you doing oh I don't
know I I don't think she meant I don't
know I think she had to go the bathroom
they're just that their whole vibe is so
strange and they're so paranoid like
with them being followed then she's like
the paparazzi have to go and do it's
like there's literally no paparazzi it's
just they have a weird vibe and they're
kind of like secretive and weird and
that's just really not a mentality you
can have when you come on to a reality
show or or you're secretive and weird
about your marriage and you want to like
be private you don't bring your husband
to really anything like look at Erika
yeah sure Tom doesn't Tom unless the
women are coming to his house you're not
seeing Tom see she learned in the
beginning too Tom got involved in like
one thing really quickly when they all
came to her house and he said something
to one of the women that was like a
little like off-colored and I don't
remember it was iconic but yeah so like
you want to be private about your
relationship don't put your relationship
on camera and I think the women would
respect that and also a lot of them are
married to like how do they file pride
like Harry Hamlin we only see him when
he wants to be baking pies yeah yeah
pitching a tent totally um I'm just like
a little over Kyle she's like really
just a lot like a little too high on her
horse yeah I was watching her like greet
someone when she walked into the party
and she was literally like looking
straight past them like yeah she was
like like if you were here hi I was like
that's what Garcelle was saying I felt
it you just don't even look at me and
you know what I love Garcelle but like
her not showing up to a group events is
really like annoying like first it was
Santa Barbara now she wasn't that Suns
thing and it's just like we need you yes
you
at anything she's or no she doesn't
attend nothing she's really like a voice
of reason and I need a Denise scan and
she is that yes she's just yes she's
very grounded and she doesn't know these
women well enough to like take alliances
or take sides
so her missing out on group events like
you have a commitment like come on let's
go yeah I'm excited for a line where she
says Lisa Rinna you're the bad guy in
this movie oh my god I just because
she's not wrong because Rinna is not
being a good friend to Denise no she's
not regardless of whether or not you
agreed like this is your friend you
brought her into the group I know that
her history like yeah decades worth of
history not just like this is your ally
on this TV show in terms of next week
with Kyle's party
why would Brandi be invited to so here's
my theory
Kyle heard a whisper that there is
something going on with Brandi and
Denise and she obviously wants to bring
it out because like it'll somehow
vindicate her in what's going on between
her and Denise um so she invited like
all these former housewives cuz
Adrienne's there Camille's there and
then she can say hey I made a brandy cuz
I made it all the girls yeah to me that
is why I'm not like Stan and Kyle the
season is she's kind of becoming the
person she accused Lisa Vanderpump of
being like this puppet master yeah and
that's not cool so when I saw that it
was gonna be Camille and Adrienne and
it's like you know all the oil coming
and I just felt like she made it all
those people so she could invite Brandi
yeah that's actually a very very good
observation and projection let's see
what happens we'll see what happens but
it was honestly boring episode but I was
just happy to have them back yeah I was
happy to have them back to tonight New
York is on I haven't watch last week yet
so I'm gonna watch the two episodes and
we can recap both fabulous there's Jim
confessionals are so lowbrow first of
all they all have different audio levels
like some of them are wearing
microphones some of them are not
LuAnn is sitting in front of like a big
picture of herself and she was a model
in the 90s like it's so messy and it's
so not premium at all like if you got
Kyle's was like halfway decent if Kyle's
on a scale of one to ten ten being
confessionals regularly Kyle zoom
confessional was like a six the women
from New Yorker litter a three Wow okay
I'm not looking forward to that but oh
I'll power through so tomorrow we'll be
recapping Real Housewives of New York
and celebrating my birthday Wow you'll
be 26
yes I'll be singing myself happy
birthday tomorrow so you don't want to
miss
that oh that's exciting and Thea will be
here I'm assuming yes a chance to
celebrate he will be here and that's all
anything else we want to say make sure
to watch my comedy special disgraced
Queen available on iTunes Apple TV and
so many other platforms head over to my
Instagram for more details anything you
want to promote uh no I started a new
book last night it was very good and
I'll share updates when I finish we have
oh we put up a new patriotic esterday oh
my gosh you guys we've done a combined
100 minutes talking about Real
Housewives history talking about former
tag lines former Housewives current
housewives all the drama from like 2010
and it's all up at patreon.com slash the
morning toast rumors are swirling
there's gonna be a chili cook-off
between Ben and I on the patreon that
you will not want to miss you will not
so head over to patreon.com slash a
morning toast to get all the tea and all
the chili and thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we record
videos on YouTube
Monday through Friday and they go up
sometime in the morning they're also
available as podcasts anywhere podcasts
can be found so that Spotify iTunes
stitcher Public Radio I have rated
cashbox all the places whoever you
listen to podcasts find us the morning
chosen leave a five star view about a
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys very much we hope you have
a fabulous time we'll see you tomorrow
for Friday